HERE TO TALK MORE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE IS BOY SCOUT EXPERT,
MATTEO LANE. MATTEO, THANKS FOR
BEING HERE.
>> SO WHAT IS IT LIKE BEING IN
THE BOY SCOUTS IN THIS DAY AND
AGE?
>> OH, I AM NOT A BOY SCOUT.
>> Larry: OH.
I AM SORRY.
BECAUSE YOU ARE DRESSED LIKE
ONE.
>> OH, SURE.
BUT THAT'S BECAUSE I AM GOING
OUT TO A BUNCH OF GAY CLUBS
LATER AND THIS OUTFIT GETS ME A
TON OF PEEN.
>> Larry: OKAY.
A TON OF PEEN.
>> PEEN. IT'S PRONOUNCED "PEEN."
>> Larry: OH, I AM SORRY.
PEEN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, LARRY.
AND THERE IS NOTHING GAYER THAN
THE BOY SCOUTS.
>> Larry: WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?  THE BOY SCOUTS ONLY JUST
STARTING ALLOWING GAY SCOUT
LEADERS.
>> LARRY, THIS IS AN ORGANIZTION
THAT HAS MEN GO OUT INTO THE
WOODS TO CAMP, SWIM AND COOK
TOGETHER, ALL WHILE WEARING
NECKERCHIEFS UNIRONICALLY.
>> Larry: SURE.
>> IT'S LIKE A LADY GAGA VIDEO,
ONLY GAYER.
>> Larry: WOW.
>> AND THIS IS NOT ABOUT
ALLOWING GAY SCOUT LEADERS.
THE BOY SCOUTS OF AMERICA
ORGANIZATION ITSELF NEEDS TO
COME OUT OF THE CLOSET.
>> Larry: WAIT, HOLD ON, JUST
BECAUSE AN ORGANIZATION PROMOTES
THOSE ACTIVITIES WITH MEN, IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN IT'S
GAY.
>> LARRY, WAKE UP AND SMELL THE
RICHLY BREWED COFFEE CAREFULLY
PREPARED BY AN OVERLY FUSSY
SCOUT LEADER THAT'S WAY BETTER
THAN IT HAS ANY RIGHT TO BE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE SOME VERY GOOD
COFFEE.
>> MARVELOUS. AND THERE ARE TONS
OF SIGNS THAT SHOULD MAKE IT
SUPER OBVIOUS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF BOY SCOUTS OF AMERICA
ADULT LEADERSHIP TRAINING BADGE
IS CALLED?
>> Larry: NO. WHAT IS IT?
>> THE WOOD BADGE, LARRY.
>> Larry: REALLY? IS THAT
TRUE?
>> OH, YES.
AND IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW, WOOD IS
A SYNONYM FOR BONER.
>> Larry: ACTUALLY, I DID KNOW
THAT. IT JUST SOUNDS LIKE YOU
ARE GENERALIZING THE THINGS THAT
GAY GUYS LIKE.
>> OH, I'M GENERALIZING.
>> Larry: YEAH.
>> KIND OF LIKE THE MORMONS DO.
>> Larry: OKAY.
FAIR ENOUGH.
I GET IT, BUT WHAT ABOUT THE BOY
SCOUT OATH, WHICH CALLS ON ALL
SCOUTS TO, QUOTE, KEEP MYSELF
PHYSICALLY STRONG, MENTALLY
AWAKE AND MORALLY STRAIGHT.
>> LARRY, THAT IS THE GAYEST
PART OF THE SCOUTS.
>> Larry: HOW IS THAT
POSSIBLE?
>> OH, STRAIGHT? IT IS THE
CLASSIC GAY MISDIRECT.
YOU KNOW, IT IS LIKE THE MORE A
POLITICIAN GOES OFF AGAINST GAY
RIGHTS, THE MORE YOU KNOW HE
GETS OFF TO LIAM HEMSWORTH.
HA, HA, HA.
OH, GOD!
ZIIIIIIING!
>> Larry: THAT IS AN AMAZING
ZING, BY THE WAY.
VERY GOOD.
>> ZING!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
BUT ISN'T IT POSSIBLE THAT THEY
JUST REALLY DON'T LIKE GAYS?
>> OH, I NEVER THOUGHT OF THAT.
I MEAN, I GUESS IT IS POSSIBLE,
LARRY.
BUT WHEN YOU REALLY BREAK IT
DOWN, NECKERCHIEFS DON'T LIE.